nesse dia de falar de empatia coube a
mim trazer uma mensagem aqui
considerando o mundo sobre a perspectiva
da criança e para começar a falar
rapidamente sobre isso eu queria falar
um pouquinho sobre mim
o petros ea grande reviravolta na vida
na verdade tudo aconteceu em 2011
quando eu morava em são paulo depois de
já ter passado uma temporada aqui no
espírito santo apesar de ser paranaense
e nasceu meu filho petros
eu trabalhava nesse momento na hp hp
mesmo de computador impressora com
treinamentos na área comportamental
adorava enlouquecida trabalhava o roriz
então estava tudo traçado o plano
o menino nasceu vou ficar quatro meses
de licença né um de férias ficou cinco
meses com a criança coloca em uma
escolinha de inteiro e volta a trabalhar
como uma louca como sempre fiz e como
sempre adorei fazer afinal de contas um
filho não pode mudar tanto assim a vida
de uma pessoa certo e errado
ele nasceu e chorou chorou e não parou
nunca mais de chorar e as pessoas diziam
ficar tranqüila são só os três primeiros
meses então até os três primeiros meses
eu estava firme e forte tranquila porque
ele chorava de noite sem parar
não é que ele trocava o dia pela noite
não acho que tem sorte as pessoas que os
filhos trocam o dia pela noite que pelo
menos dorme de dia
não ele não dormir ele tinha espasmos de
20 minutos quando né
estava morto e aí é enfim eu descobri
que eu realmente não sabia nada desse
negócio de criança com quatro meses que
ele tinha no durante a
licença-maternidade férias nós voltamos
para a vitória em mudança então estava
tudo certo eu ia ser transferida
trabalhar na hp vitória beleza tudo
certo entrevista já está agendada com
gestor daqui estava tudo ok mas ele não
parou de chorar os três meses nem nos
quatro meses nem nos cinco meses quando
eu deveria fazer a entrevista então
pedir demissão por telefone e falei eu
preciso dar conta desse negócio aqui que
eu tô conseguindo
eu sempre tão autoconfiante e vou
resolver deixa que eu faço desde que eu
aconteço isso não estava conseguindo
definitivamente e aí quando ele não
parou algumas pessoas começaram a dizer
não tem criança que vai até os seis
meses né
seis meses não parou de chorar sete
meses não parou de chorar ele teve uma
série de complicações na e não parou de
chorar quando ele tinha oito meses
chorando uma amiga falou assim mas em
casa já leu um livro sobre bebês eu
falei existe e eu descobrir a primeira
coisa que eu acho muito interessante de
trazer que na nossa cultura a gente não
tem a idéia de estudar para ser pai e
mãe
a gente acha que pra isso não precisa
agora é tão interessante porque a gente
pode suportar qualquer coisa que dê
errado na nossa vida mas um filho que dá
errado a gente nunca vai superar a gente
vai pra sempre se perguntar onde foi que
eu errei que eu poderia ter feito
diferente
enfim uma das coisas que eu descobri
hora que eu li esse livro que eu fui
estudar eu resolvi me aprofundar e eu
resolvi não parar mais de estudar isso
mudou minha vida tem a ver com esse
vídeo
é
[Música]
eu vou seguir perguntando é possível que
essa criança estivesse fingindo ou
manipulando quem acha que sim
levanta a mão por favor levanta de
verdade bacana
quantos anos tem essa criança no máximo
no máximo 2 estourando se ela tiver
máximo é dois corréus aos dois anos as
crianças ainda não falam plenamente
falam algumas coisas umas mais outras
menos mas ela não tem todo potencial
vocabulário possibilidade de comunicação
que a gente tem quando adulto né então
quais são as formas de comunicação mais
comuns de uma criança os dois anos
o choro e oi
o riso choro né e as movimentações
corporais
então é dotada dessa potência de
comunicação e desses recursos que ela
tem
a criança vai tentar comunicar o que ela
precisa ela ainda não sabe não tem idéia
do que seja fingir ou manipular ela só
conta com esses recursos de comunicação
portanto quando eu olho para essa
criança e pensa ela está fingindo
manipulando é porque estou olhando para
ela com a cabeça do adulto do adulto se
eu olho para ela com a cabeça da criança
eu sei que ela não tem condições ainda
de fingir ou manipular ela está
comunicando alguma necessidade que eu
não sei qual pode ser em números mas é o
jeito que ela sabe agora é tão
inteligente aos 2 anos que ela já
percebeu que não adianta chorar sozinha
ela sabe que é o adulto que resolve as
situações que ela precisa que resolvi
então ela vai até ele e chora e se joga
no chão e fala por favor da opção de
você pra alguma coisa e o adulto acha
super engraçado fillmann sai de cena vai
publicando espera criança vive e dá
risada
no youtube porque é muito engraçado ver
a criança isso ela está sofrendo
se a gente soubesse o tanto que ela pode
estar sofrendo então a gente não acha
mais graça
depois de assistir filme ela pode estar
querendo comunica a inúmeras coisas a
gente precisa olhar com a cabeça da
criança se não a gente fala fala fala
fala de empatia mas demora conseguir
fazer isso é muito interessante na nossa
cultura a gente está acostumado diz
respeito às crianças
o caso do igor eu quero trazer para
vocês eu conheci o igor numa consulta
pediátrica pro meu filho enquanto
esperava a vez dele
o igor está lá eo igor estava com cara
de quem queria conversar
vocês já perceberam que eu não gosto e
eu perguntei
comecei a puxar papo e ele falou oi eu
comecei o nome igor é que legal meu
também começa com isso a é aí tentou
adivinhar aquelas brincadeiras e tal e
aí ele disse eu disse quantos anos você
tem e depois os dedinhos assim disse 4
firewall que minam não é bonitão com
quatro anos e tal a mãe virou e falou
isso é porque não conhece é terrível
eu não queria dizer pra cantar
conversando com ela que eu ser
indelicada
mas era verdade eu não tava conversando
com ela complicou a conversa porque o
igor nessa hora
buscando atender à expectativa do adulto
especialmente o adulto de referência a
mãe fez uma cara de terrível e contou
uma coisa de terrível sem contexto
nenhum e gol disparou eu joguei o prato
na professora
a mãe falou menino seu pai ficar sabendo
a apanhar a ele disse a ele disse não
ele fez isso eu disse né
é porque eu sem querer vamos combinar
que haveria essa hipótese
ele disse por querer citar é complicando
me ajuda
e aí eu falei mas por que você quis
jogar o prato na professora
ele falou porque eu estava colocando a
minha toalha em cima da mesa
ela veio com a toalhinha jogou no canto
e botou prata assim eu fiquei com raiva
angel prato nela
longe de mim dizer que o igor está certo
de jogar o prato a professora não vim
aqui pra isso
longe de mim dizer que ele tem razão
jogar o prato
eu também não vim aqui pra isso mas eu
ouso dizer que a professora não faria
isso com um adulto que com um adulto ela
esperaria de terminar de colocar a
toalha respeitosamente depois colocaria
o prato mas é uma criança só uma toalha
só uma criança tem importância nenhuma
o importante é fazer rápido que eu tenho
hora para cumprir
eu ouso dizer que o igor foi
desrespeitado e no auge da sua
maturidade de quatro anos só sobrou o
piloto automático de uma pessoa de
temperamento forte pá e se a gente ainda
bati no menino faz o menino lá pedir
desculpa a gente diz respeito a ele de
novo sem parar província em conversar
sem dar opções pra ele do que fazer
então com a raiva que sente que a
inteligência emocional
mas não é só com igor que isso acontece
quando a gente visita amigos quem tem
filho vai pra casa dos outros amigos que
também tem filhos
a gente chega porque a gente quer chegar
a gente fica porque a gente quis ficar
ea criança quando a gente chega é
obrigada a se enturmar com a criança que
está lá querendo ou não gostando ou não
tendo afinidade ou não porque a gente
vai na casa do amigo pela nossa
afinidade não necessariamente pela
afinidade da criança com a criança dele
e aí ela no começo às vezes não está
muito à vontade ela fala quer embora só
vai lá brincar e aí a criança obrigado
então a interagir ela acaba interagindo
ela acaba conseguindo ela acaba gostando
e aí ele demora mais tempo que você e
tal pra você já deu e aí a gente fala tá
bom tá na hora de ir embora a gente vai
lá agora vamos embora na altura brincar
que vão embora tá na hora já falei que a
gente não quer saber se ela quer embora
a gente quer saber que agora é hora de
ir embora ea gente não está preocupado
se ela quer ir embora assim como a gente
não estava preocupada ela queria ficar
isso acontece rotineiramente é a gente
nem percebe é comum em adultos que só
cumprimentou um adulto se a gente
encontra as pessoas com a criança do
lado a pessoa vem cumprimento todos os
adultos presentes não cumprimenta
crianças acontece ea gente muitas vezes
não estranho
acha que pode acontecer que é aceitável
e normal
uma vez meu filho já me perguntou por
que ele não me cumprimentou falei não
sei realmente não sei ele está
equivocado mas também já avisei
infelizmente é normal na nossa cultura
pode acontecer outras vezes falha você
foi lamentável tudo dizer não pode né a
criança pega um objeto perigoso alguma
coisa que oferece algum risco ao adulto
vai lá com a melhor das intenções
porque afinal de contas o meu filho não
tivesse chorado oito meses eu não
saberia essas coisas eu também faria
tudo isso assim cheia de boa intenção
a gente vai lá e tira o objeto daquela
fase não pode a criança pequenininha
então quando eu fizer alguma coisa
mandou outro fator que tira maneira isso
é ela vai no parquinho
a iminente brincando com o objeto que
ela quer ela vai lá
ai ai vai não é assim se você quer você
tem que pedir educadamente é foi isso
que fez o gol e pouco lá em casa não né
então a gente vai passando um monte de
mensagem que a gente acha que está
passando um homem na verdade está
passando outros lugares em que as
crianças não são bem vindas a gente
devia ter na nossa sociedade todos os
ambientes preparados para receber também
as crianças que são indivíduos como
qualquer um de nós
embora a gente fala que nem gente não
tem nem tamanho de gente não tem que
querer nada se é criança né
e as crianças não são bem-vindas uma das
rejeições que as crianças tenham o
trabalho dos pais é porque o lugar que
elas não podem e que toma o pai ea mãe
delas todo dia o dia inteiro
as crianças não são bem-vindas não são
bem vindas em reuniões não são bem
vindas e muitos eventos não são bem
vindas em muitos lugares do mundo como
difícil a criança no mundo de hoje
a aula preferida na escola o sinal gente
quando a criança vai pra escola ela tem
que nesta data tudo mas de repente ela
descobrir alguma coisa que ela gosta ela
se interessa que ela está apaixonada e
aquela história dele se ela não tá vendo
o tempo passar
tá tem que estudar outra coisa mas eu
queria que ele tem que querer nada agora
tem que estudar isso aqui é hora de isso
aqui acabou obrigado a dormir na escola
sabia que tem isso tem escola que tem a
hora do soninho a criança tem que dormir
eu não dormi sabe que ela é terrível
operativa pode escolher
lamentavelmente daqui a pouco a gente
começa a ritalina as crianças que era
desobediente canon dono
é lamentável que a gente está fazendo o
bebê jogado um objeto no chão ele está
descobrindo os movimentos ele descobre
que quando ele abre os dedinhos objeto
cair
ae faz barulho deixa eu ver se de novo a
a alguém pegue trás ele faz de novo
fazer cócegas a pessoa jogou lá é de
novo a pessoa me falou você jogar de
novo vou guardar em um governo que está
fazendo de proposta
ele estava só se desenvolvimento só
aprendendo tudo sobre a vida
você não tem que querer nada quando as
crianças já ouviram isso não tem que
aprender o abcd não tem que aprender a
obedecer
é isso que a gente espera das crianças
só que depois no mercado de trabalho a
gente quer arrojo a gente quer
iniciativa a gente quer criatividade a
gente quer interesse a gente quer a
gente quer persistência persistência na
infância conhecida como teimosia pra
vocês terem idéia que a gente procure
estirpar todo custo pois faz falta pra
caramba na vida
volta pra caramba na vida tem gente pais
de adolescentes que me procuram sendo
que nem trabalho com essa faixa etária
mas acho que o desespero ou a esperança
eles me procuram e dizem que eu faço meu
filho não quer nada com nada falou por
acaso na infância ele ouviu você não tem
que querer nada com ele era criança am
a gente planta na infância e cole na
vida adulta
vida adulta e as crianças possuem
empatia já ouviram falar que a gente
nasce com a empatia os neurônios
espelhos e aí eu queria contar pra vocês
um caso interessante de um amigo inglês
que foi nos visitar em são paulo e foi
né como todo bom turista fazê-la o
mercado municipal
enquanto esperávamos um sanduíche de
mortadela tinha aquele potinho lindo no
centro da mesa com coisinhas redondinhas
né de várias cores verde laranja amarela
vermelha e não deu nem tempo de avisar
ele pegou um palito de dente e era o que
é pimenta e ele soltou fogo pelas ventas
o negócio horroroso e eu contei isso
numa mesa com um monte de amigo e agente
morreu de rir todo mundo riu dessa
história porque foi realmente muito
engraçado e meu filho sérgio estava com
três anos me cutucou depois que todo
mundo riu e falou assim não foi
engraçado para ele
eles têm empatia
a gente dá um duro danado pra acabar com
ela e depois começar a fazer cursos e
retomar veja você que ponto chegamos nós
estamos fazendo curso de humanização
humanização do atendimento humanização
do parto humanização da saúde a gente
virou que ela tem que fazer cursos para
humanizar um pedido que eu tenho pra
gente fechar não faça para o outro que
você gostaria que fizessem pra você por
favor não faça isso faça para o outro
aquilo que o outro sendo assim como ele
é
estando no momento de vida que ele está
ficando na faixa etária que ele está
gostaria ou precisaria que fizesse pra
ele que eu faço do outro como eu
gostaria que fizesse pra mim o foco
continua aqui eu faço para o outro como
ele gostaria que eu fizesse pra ele eu
tenho que parar e olhar pra ele e aí eu
vou ter que fazer diferente para cada um
um país de mais de um filho sabem que as
coisas não funcionam igual
duas crianças diferentes que deus
abençoe que a gente consiga de verdade
se colocar no lugar do outro
obrigada
[Aplausos]